for the tampa bay rays it's going to be
right-hander chris archer
making his first appearance for the
raise since april the
10th he drops a strike in there
off speed to get hernandez looking
swain and the miss he strikes out robert
runner goes 3-2 swing and a miss
he gets the strikeout of jimenez and
strikes out the side they're going to be
facing ronaldo lopez uh ever since he's
been starting this year every start he's
had he's been lights out so two ounce
runner at third base and here is austin
meadows now the 2-2
and a liner that ball's going to be a
base hit
into right and the raise will take the
lead
wants it in nope right back to the
middle once that ball gets in the middle
of the plate this time
austin meadows does not miss it he gets
it
into right field and the rays take the
lead g-man choi gingerly coming down
third base we're looking at yandi diaz
and he is taking over at first base
g-man choi
wander franco grounded the first is only
time
there's a shot into deep center field
robert on the run looking up and it's
going to be off the wall
here comes diaz it's going to be a
double for franco and the rays tank on
another run
wander franco
continues to sting that baseball at the
fastball up he goes and needs it out in
front what a great job by wander franco
from one at bat to the next saying
you're not getting me up there again
and he meets the ball out in front of
the plate and drives it to the big part
of the field
well he extends his hitting streak to
seven
and he's on base streak
these meadows and there's a little
looper into center that's going to fall
here comes franco
meadows drives in its second run
on consecutive pitches the rays pick up
two runs
austin meadows once again this ball in a
little bit
he stays inside of it just kind of
inside outside out into shallow left
center field
another run another rbi
this into right and goodwin does track
it down before it hits the carpet and
ronaldo lopez celebrates nice play on a
reed by goodwin in right
great play by goody right here i mean
this ball is really hit hard and that's
the only reason it's caught is because
it stays up long enough for goody to
catch is about 104.7 off the bat great
play that kind of sinking at the end
right there and uh goodwin with a nice
play to
kill any sort of rally great depth
in places some people didn't expect that
lopez wipes away mejia and it gets a one
two three inning two outs two minutes
scoring possession
and the 3-2 pitch on its way
struck them out
they leave two
do not score
in the bottom of the sixth inning wonder
franco will lead off against garrett
crochet
in the first pitch from the left he
swung on on a high fly ball left center
field that's tagged well going to be off
the wall
extra bases bronco hit it second
with a double
raised runners at first and second and
bring up joey wendell
3-2
it's a fastball for strike three in the
top of the zone and two down here jose
ruiz
is on with the bases loaded
pitch
he shoots it up the gap in right center
field that ball is going to be over the
glove of goodwin
bronco scores the rosarina scores here
comes phillips it's a double
three run double from ahia
what a mess of an inning for the white
sox
from the walk to the o2 pitch it's a
fastball
[Applause]
[Music]
i guess you'd say outer half of the
plate but much too
hittable
and mejia did exactly that rockets that
ball out into right center field
phillips on first base running on
contact scores easily and you just
doubled your lead
the swing and missed by kirbyr who's out
on strikes the rays
sends seven men to the plate
they score three
sox have two one with one out in the
seventh
chop toward the middle
out at 7.
broncos throw to first takes care of
that
exactly what fleming was looking for
so back-to-back walks and wander franco
is making his way to the flight
[Music]
3-2 on the ground backhanded at second
out there throw to first not in time
well hernandez
came up with it got the force on diaz at
second base
the rage will have been on the corners
out of that
the balk has been called
jerry davis the third base umpire
has called the ball and that's going to
give the reigns another run
[Applause]
see what ruiz did
oh right there a little hesitation
[Applause]
that's going to be fair
and bound down toward the bullpen
here comes franco
into second goes meadows
and he picks up another run batted in
his third of the day
this ball down and in just kind of
sliced
up in the air
trying to find where this ball went and
again another ball by the rays that just
falls into no man's land gets a good
kick
another run
sox have two on nobody out here in the
eighth inning
line drive short stop back to second oh
he got it he is out there
what is so impressive to me about these
plays is the reaction not a franco but
of loud how lau is able to get to the
back so that plays happens now i know
he's close to the bag
but this ball goes into the glove and
it's just immediately turn and throw you
know your guy's gonna be there
and lau
was how about it not the typical josh
fleming double play
but a double play nonetheless
then on the corners
for kevin kiermeier
there's a liner into left and that's
going to be caught tag at third
phillips will cross the plate the run
batted in for tiermeyer
on what turns into a sacrifice fly
josh fleming
set to begin his third inning of work
line drive oh it's caught boyd some good
hang time right there
bronco went up
and stayed up for a while
get up young man
how busy has he been
he's been all over the place go back to
that last half inning he had the air
started the double play ended the inning
started this inning catches that line
drive he's been a one-man wrecking crew
here the last couple innings
round ball this should do it out at
first
lauda diaz
three up and three down
and the raves have shut out
the white sox nine to nothing
you